ciao a tutti ragazzi bentornati una
nuova puntata di mi rassegno stampa
adesso quello di maggio è stato un mese
carico carico di avvenimenti importanti
avvenimenti che io non ho minimamente
seguito perché sono stato impegnatissimo
a lamentarmi di questo clima di merda
ora per chi non lo sapesse maggio è quel
mese che ha trentuno giorni ognuno dei
quali parte comunque il sapore estivo di
danza kuduro e finisce alla sera con la
scrit mans dei wham
parliamo subito però con quello che
secondo me è stato veramente il grande
evento di questo mese questo mese
sarebbe potuto iniziare e finire in
questo modo con questo grande
approfondimento che faremo oggi sul
royal wedding
adesso harry winston e megan traynor mar
coll
come si chiama lei e meghan markle si
sono sposati sono convogliati a nozze
sono felicissimi e noi non potremmo
essere più felici per loro unica diciamo
nota dolente è stato sicuramente sono
parte investito di lei criticato anche
da enzo miccio e senza un ice t critica
il matrimonio anche se se la reggina è
affatto un matrimonio di merda questo os
con la barca diciamo che è affondato al
primo passo dentro la chiesa inoltre
diceva anche che non si porta un
braccialetto se sei una sposa perché sei
già così agghindata che mettere il
braccialetto che cazzo lo fa io aggiungo
pure il braccetto toglie importanza
l'anello come se tutti facessimo pelli
nuovi ma un tatuaggio in faccia e dice
si è notato qualcosa di diverso siamo
contenti per loro ma forse è la cosa più
interessante del matrimonio fra rm gun è
stato david beckham
parliamone bono bono bono bono diciamo
che internet è stato pregno di commenti
sostanziosi non ancora superato le foto
di david beckham di ieri
vabbè david sì lo voglio victoria è
stata criticata ma il muso lungo le
c'era sempre
mamma mia dall'altra parte miliardi cioè
no alla forza comunque di mantenere
questo questo contegno e questa questa
plomb a un contegno che ti posso dire
potrebbe passare per gioia se vai ad
analizzare il viso di un'altra persona
perché perché al matrimonio era anche
presente la ex di harry e questa è stata
la sua faccia durante tutta quanta la
cerimonia
vabbè diciamo che lei ha scelto è optato
per un look opposto a quello della della
sposa che era in bianco è optato per un
total black in un certo senso è stata
una un'allegoria una sorta di legge del
contrappasso diciamo che la nostra come
che si chiama lei la nostra ex diciamo
che sperava che al posto della sposa
all'interno delle chiese in trasse una
bara e questa era vestita per
l'occasione
ma andiamo avanti adesso come in passato
un maria e giuseppe dovettero
abbandonare betlemme per arrivare a
nazareth chiara e fedex tornano in
patria con il loro pargoletto leone gesù
lucia ferragni instagram allora va
veramente dire chiara fede voi siete
minori brangelina io se posso questo
natale faccio un presepe il vostro onore
metto leoncino come gesù come stella
cometa una cosa importante fare un
grande in bocca al lupo a fede j ax per
nel concerto del primo giugno ma sentivo
di farlo anche perché secondo me si
sposa benissimo questo augurio con la
prossima notizia che rimane sempre
all'interno del panorama della musica
italiana parliamo di un di un astro
nascente parliamo in un certo senso di
un visionario e di un grande paroliere
ecco l'incrocio perfetto fra mozart e
mogol si chiama young signorino ed è il
tormentone
tutti parlano di young signorino ci è o
ci fa
lo abbiamo chiesto a big fish beh grazie
che è un pochino come chiedere a lory
del santo che cosa pensa di paolo
sorrentino cioè non lo so se come un
modo innovativo per insultare qualcuno
effettivamente ecco vedere che io prendo
ispirazione per come chiesto da marc
jacobs capitolo tomba roncato vi dico
solo che le canzoni di questo ragazzo 19
anni le canta anche mia zia nel momento
in cui mia zia cantano da conso devo
vedere se veramente arrivato ovunque per
chi non lo conoscesse citiamo alcuni dei
suoi testi delle sue opere ecco forse
sarebbe più giusto di scrivere così la
danza dell'ambulanza e padre satana ma
ecco una cosa importante che si
definisce il milf del trap o anche il
marylin manson italiano o anche no ma
continuiamo a parlare di satana e
spostiamoci al met gala mezzala è stato
a tema papesse angeli e creature maligne
ma qual è stato il tema nel mercato
esattamente e abbiamo rihanna che siete
da papa abbiamo rianda che si veste
grazie match cala questa esclusiva
abbiamo un blake lively
ma ragazzi facciamo resti di pazzeschi
ragazzi katy perry e black swan mai
vista sarah jessica parker e la madonna
comunque parliamo sempre di moda
rimaniamo sempre nell'ambito e andiamo a
parlare un pochino della
a venere nera siamo tutti contenti del
l'aitante mourinho mi cambi perché compì
48 anni e sembri mia sorella
ora io posso fare una domanda cioè ma
ste persone
ok che se intaccato di soldi ma cos'è
che fa esattamente
rimaniamo sempre a parlare però comunque
di bellezza nina moric dice non ho fatto
nessun intervento chirurgico
non so perché abbiano tagliato al
ginocchio però andiamo avanti
cristiano ronaldo ennesima prova costume
superata e finalmente ci svela la sua
dieta ecco mostrandoci semplicemente un
self i al ristorante ora la mia domanda
è da quando il cibo che fotografie
quello che ti mangi sappiamo che tutte
quante le st g prendono il panino lo
appoggiano alla bocca e poi lo fiom ma
cristiano è il fritto tema il monte
magno inflitto dei calamari questo
quella del tavolo vicino e gli ha detto
scorse quando posso fare una foto
io faccio il contrario invece io sto
facendo un periodo nel quale faccio
vedere tutti quanti di essere superati i
30 di ieri mi sono mangiato una
carbonara come fai a non averla mangiata
non la photographie ed è come se non
fosse esistita è questa qui era la foto
dopo l'abbuffata [ __ ] concludiamo
questa rubrica con una carrellata molto
veloce questo mese è stato anche il mese
nel quale l'uomo ha chiamato la polizia
per aver ricevuto un piatto di cozze
troppo piccolo abbiamo avuto un'altra
donna che ha comprato una banana online
e l'ha pagata
mille euro a da questo va affrontato
assolutamente un possiamo passarci sopra
gli anni orrore il vestito è giallo oro
e blu e nero the new frontiera
praticamente io sentivo le altre cose mi
hanno spiegato che assenti 1 senti
l'altro io sapere che cosa
thiene che vuol dire mi senti se ti dico
mi sentii anni allora ragazzi ma non è
che lo reale in realtà ayane real e noi
abbiamo sempre sentito male a parte
queste cose abbiamo liberato che ha
fatto il concerto il 9 maggio ma che non
si ha ancora svelato c'è stato cannes ma
sti cazzi un pò che si è sballato di
cannes ad amsterdam è morto per finta e
di marty fra il morto per davvero suo
fratello olmi e philip roth
chi sono i vivi del mese abbiamo la
regina elisabetta
roberto saviano pippo baudo che campa
senza problemi il vaglio un top andrea
d'amante fan
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video non dimenticatevi di
iscrivervi al canale e di lasciare un
commento qua sotto facendomi sapere qual
è stata la notizia che vi è piaciuta e
magari non facendomi sapere se ne sono
persa qualcuna così che commentiamo qua
sotto altre notizie io come sempre vi
auguro un buon inizio di giugno e vi
lascio con la frase del mese una volta
ho aperto un minibar e dentro c'era un
barista nono